historian Michael Beschloss is author of
the new book the conquerors Roosevelt
Truman and the destruction of Hitler's
Germany 1941 to 1945 recently he spoke
at the US Navy Memorial Theatre in
Washington DC for about an hour it's my
pleasure tonight to introduce officially
our speaker although Tom you've you've I
should have just said let's move on to
the to the headline Michael Beschloss is
a nationally recognized historian of the
American presidency and as Thomas
pointed out as well a friend and avid
patron of the National Archives he's a
familiar figure particularly in our
presidential libraries where he's done
research for six previous books in
regard to the presidency for his two
recent volumes in the White House tapes
of Lyndon Johnson he transcribed
hundreds of hours of recordings at the
LBJ library his books on the president's
revealed our greatness and their
weaknesses in their own words and those
of their closest associates they also
highlight the richness of the
documentary sources and demonstrate that
the writing and perception of history is
not static as records are released and
declassified or simply brought to light
after being long forgotten gaps in our
knowledge are filled and familiar
stories become new again Michael combed
through newly released American Soviet
and British records to produce the book
that Sam pointed out that we'll hear
about tonight the conquerors records at
the National Archives
notably those of course at the Roosevelt
Library in the Truman library figure
prominently in this examination of the
Allied leadership during World War two I
had the honor as has Tom and others to
work with Michael in conjunction with
the foundation and on his board as were
likewise myself are very proud to have
for the last two years I appreciate very
much your support your commitment to our
effort and
extend my welcome as well to everyone
for attending tonight Michael Beschloss
is also a trustee of the White House
Historical Association the Thomas
Jefferson Foundation and the University
of Virginia's Miller center of public
affairs and he may be familiar to a lot
of you as he is with us the regular
commentator on the ABC News and PBS news
hour with Jim Lehrer ladies and
gentlemen Michael Beschloss John that
was awfully nice thanks can everyone
hear alright the acoustics here really
seem to be wonderful but if they're not
please someone if they could raise their
hand John was so kind to mention the
news hour with Jim Lehrer and especially
to call it the news hour with Jim Lehrer
I think the rest of us still called the
macneil/lehrer Newshour I think even
people who have worked there for a long
time I'd always remember reminds me of
what was said some years ago no longer
true some guy once said that PBS public
broadcasting comes in five parts and he
said the five parts are hope I'm gonna
get this right animals talking English
people talking animals mating English
people mating and the news hour with Jim
Lehrer I could have saved John and Tom
an awful lot of time by just coming here
and saying I'm the one from category
five John and Tom talked about the
National Archives and I need not tell
anyone here I'm sure what a national
treasure they are having spent many
summers and many winters in them since I
was about 17 years old and the thing
when you work there especially the
presidential libraries this is true of
the National Archives as well you begin
to take on the characteristics of the
people that you're studying which in the
case I guess if you're writing about
Mahatma Gandhi or mother Teresa would be
fine
when you're writing about someone like
Lyndon Johnson it's something of a more
mixed experience you can take on the
guy's qualities and as I was doing those
two books on the Johnson tapes that John
was kind enough to mention I'd hear
these stories
and worried that I would become a living
incarnation of Lyndon Johnson and the
one that really did it for me was true
story
Johnson was about to give a speech and
asked one of his speech writers to do
the text of the speech and the speech
writer brought in the text and it began
with a big quotation from Aristotle as
Aristotle said so Johnson looked at the
text and he said well the speech is fine
and I like the quotation at the
beginning but no one is going to know
who the hell Aristotle was so he said
just keep the quote and change it to as
my daddy said it's a kind of thing it
worked wonderfully for Johnson it would
not do wonders for me as in a story and
I assure you and the other thing that
occurs to me since John was talking
about the archives the Johnson library
was opened in the spring of 1971 I
believe John I think it was May and
Johnson was very competitive he wanted
more people to attend the Johnson
library to come there than any other
library in the system certainly the
Roosevelt library the Eisenhower library
and it was rough going because that
first spring the war in Vietnam was
still on and Johnson was having a hard
time getting people to come to a museum
to the glories of Lyndon Johnson who was
the father one of the fathers of a war
that was very controversial even then
and the numbers were not great and the
story is told by people who were on the
staff who were there then the Johnson
knew that because just about every day
he'd call up and say how many people
came to my library yesterday and then
give him an answer that did not please
him and they knew because they'd hear
this enormous grunt from the other end
of the line probably worried that he
would give them bad reviews and
jeopardize their jobs and so finally
according to them with grim battlefield
humor among themselves that began
referring to this daily figure as the
body count
and like an earlier body count they were
attempted to start inflating the figures
to please the boss and even that didn't
work so as the apparently true story is
told in the fall of 1971 how many here
have actually seen the Johnson library
or know where it is well quite a few
down in Austin it's across a street from
the University of Texas football stadium
where tens of thousands come every
Saturday Linden got an idea and the idea
was this he called up apparently the guy
who makes announcements at halftime
during those well attended football
games and said make an announcement at
halftime saying anyone who wants to take
a leak or get some cool water can do it
at the Johnson library across the street
and apparently thousands of people
flowed through the front doors and by
the end of 1971 the Johnson library was
the best attended Presidential Library
in the system and I know that John is
going to correct me if I'm wrong but I
think it is pretty near maybe the third
best attended Presidential Library in
the system it's still doing extremely
well and so the point I'm making is that
when you study presidents and when you
study historical figures you learn what
they did right and you also learn in
some cases what they did wrong the book
I'm here to talk about tonight as John
and Tom mentioned is a book called the
conquerors the subtitle is Roosevelt
Truman and the destruction of Hitler's
Germany 1941 to 1945 which as I've
suggested I spent an awful time and well
sometimes awful awfully long time as
well
in the National Archives in the
Presidential Library System researching
and it just gives you an idea of the
treasures that we've got here I mean I
found you know if I listed them it would
just take all night but just a couple of
the collections I used the captured
documents that are armies brought back
from Germany after VE Day in World War
Two and another is the Venona
transcripts transcripts that were
released of intercepted communications
between Soviet agents in Moscow and
Soviet agents in the United States that
our signals intelligence had intercepted
during World War two
and finally were released a few years
ago and the most interesting collection
I found and that I really used a lot of
is something that is called the Henry
Morgenthau diary and the Henry
Morgenthau diary is probably a pretty
deceptive word for this because it
sounds like someone just sort of jotting
into a diary every night and what this
was was Henry Morgenthau who was FDR a
secretary of the Treasury 12-years was
there in that job almost for the entire
Roosevelt administration Roosevelt's
closest friend in government he not only
would dictate very exact accounts of
what FDR had told him and what he told
Roosevelt but he actually had what I
think is probably the first presidential
recording system and what he apparently
had this is still a little bit fuzzy we
don't know all the details but he
apparently had a system that would
record on big plastic platters which is
what you did in those days
and the recorder went to a microphone
that was in his office and it was also
on his telephone line and the result was
that almost all the important
conversations at Morgenthau had all the
way through the New Deal and all the way
through World War two were recorded and
they were transcribed the original
recordings apparently have vanished I
think they were probably destroyed but
we've got exact transcripts of what all
these people told one another in the
1930s in the 1940s I use them a lot to
write this book and the result is that
you can write about FDR and Truman and
the people around them almost as exactly
as you can about Lyndon Johnson from
these tapes that LBJ made of his
conversations and that is only because
the National Archives has been such a
good steward of this collection and has
preserved it so the people like me can
use it one thing I should also say about
that some people in Washington knew that
Morgenthau had this he thought secret
recording system Joe Kennedy the father
President Kennedy who was also a new
dealer thought that it wasn't a
recording system but just a woman was
listening in on the telephone line
transcribing the conversation so Kennedy
got an idea he didn't want
conversation transcribed and this was he
thought a very prissy woman who was
listening in so he would say hello Henry
when he called Morgenthau and then there
would be this huge burst of profanity as
lurid as possible with the idea that
when this prissy lady heard the way that
Joe Kennedy talked she would immediately
hang up and the conversation would go
unrecorded for history
little did Kennedy know that it was
actually a machine which captured every
word what the book is about is I think
one of the best things that the United
States has ever done and that is this if
we were meeting in 1945 at the end of
World War two even after our victory
there was a Gallup poll of Americans and
the question was even though we have won
the war do you think there will be
another world war waged by Germany and
do you think there will be some future
version of that of Hitler and despite
the fact that we had won the war a vast
majority of Americans said yes there was
a feeling at that time that Germans were
by nature warlike they had caused three
wars during the lifetime of many people
than living franco-prussian war and two
world wars and many people thought that
it was almost in the German blood stream
that this was going to happen again and
that as Americans we had to expect that
even though we went through that
sacrifice in World War two this would be
a dark specter in our future and what
the book is about is how FDR and how
Harry Truman at the end of World War two
fought World War two in a way that 50 or
60 years later it's the last thing that
we have to worry about Germany has its
ups and downs but Germany today is
peaceful and democratic we have all
sorts of worries in the world but one of
them thank God is the worry that we
Americans might have to one day fight
Germany once again led by some future
version of an a Dolf Hitler and the book
begins in July of 1944 and it begins
with a scene Adolf Hitler had a retreat
that was called the Wolf's Lair
appropriately enough
the wolf's lair was an East Prussia
which is now Poland and Hitler went
there oftentimes during the summer it
was very hot and what the scene shows is
this Hitler was there July of 1944 he
was meeting with a lot of the people who
worked for him they were telling him
that the war was not going well for the
Germans d-day it happened six weeks
earlier the Russians were advancing from
the east he was in a foul mood what he
did not know was that among the people
who were briefing him in that hot room
as he was mopping his forehead with a
handkerchief was a young officer named
Klaus von Stauffenberg and Klaus
finished off in Berg was 37 years old he
was a very noble man he had fought in
Tunisia and when he was fighting in
Tunisia fighting the Allies an allied
lion landmine went off blew off seven of
his fingers blew out his eye so this was
someone with one eye only three fingers
but in the wake of that he began hearing
about Nazi brutality especially in
Russia and he began to think that Hitler
is a horrible thing for Germany and
something must be done and the something
he thought must be done is for Hitler to
be killed and in 1944 there was a very
loose conspiracy of people for all sorts
of reasons to try to murder
Adolf Hitler all sorts of reasons some
of them wanted future generations not to
think that all Germans were Nazis some
wanted to make a separate peace maybe
with the Americans or with the Russians
there were a few not many who were
unhappy with Hitler's war against the
Jews and so they were motivated to join
this conspiracy
they tried many times to kill Hitler it
never worked by the summer of 44 he was
still alive Stauffenberg thought that
this was going to be his moment he was
called to Hitler's presence in the wolf
the Wolf's Lair in this barracks
it was nearly noon he brought in a
briefcase and inside the briefcase was a
shirt and inside the shirt was a ticking
time bomb despite the fact that he only
had three fingers in one eye he taught
himself to use those three fingers to
detonate a bomb that would then tick and
then finally go off so what he did was
he took the briefcase into the room
shoved it under the table excused
himself and went outside the barracks
and then around noontime he saw a huge
explosion there was a swirl of blue
flame boards were flying all over the
place he knew that Hitler could not
possibly have survived and in fact he
saw a stretcher carried out with
Hitler's cloak over a body and he
assumed that he had just seen the
lifeless body of a Dolf Hitler and so
what he did was he had conspirators he
was whisked away to a getaway plane he
was flown to Berlin he met with other
chief plotters at military headquarters
and said Hitler has been assassinated
now is the time for us to declare the
coup and declare a new German government
and some of the plotters said well we
have other information that Hitler is
not dead and he said absolutely Hitler
is dead I saw his body carried out of
the room there's no way he's alive by
then there was news from the Wolf's Lair
that Hitler actually had survived and
the reason he had survived was the
ticking time bomb in that briefcase went
off but the briefcase had been shoved to
the other side of a big oak support
which protected Hitler from the bomb
going off so his hair was singed he was
burned but he was still alive very
quickly the plotters were discovered and
Hitler said show them no mercy they
should be executed immediately and as
far as Stalin Berg was concerned not
only should Stefan burrow be killed he
said but every single member of his
family down to the last one and there
was a scene that very night at military
headquarters on bend ler Street in
Berlin a building that still stands
where Stauffenberg was executed by a
firing squad and the last words out of
his mouth were long live our eternal
Germany in other words the Germany that
lived before
Adolphe Hitler and Hitler went on he
knew that the plot was afoot by now and
wanted to make sure that every possible
conspirator was killed so that he
couldn't be in danger and there was a
purge probably five million German that
five thousand Germans were captured and
in one case some of the chief plotters
were brought to a courtyard and they
were put on meat hooks and this was done
particularly to sort of torture
in a way that would get out so that
anyone else would be dissuaded from this
they were put on meat hooks these were
all men they wore trousers that had no
belts so that as they were rioting in
their death agony the trousers would
drop off so they were not would not even
have the dignity of being clothes as
they died and not only this
Hitler decreed that a motion picture of
this thing be made and flown to him
which it was and he and Joseph Goebbels
his chief propagandist watched this
movie apparently the people squirming on
the meat hooks even googles who was
known to be quite cold-blooded couldn't
stand it and apparently had to close his
eyes to keep from passing out but that
was the summer of 1944 and that's the
beginning of the book and switched to
Franklin Roosevelt Franklin Roosevelt at
that point was in San Diego too pretty
to accept the Democratic nomination for
the fourth time for president he gets
the news that there was a plot against
Hitler then he hears that the plot has
failed and so I began when I was
studying all this you know what was
Roosevelt's reaction early on I thought
Roosevelt was probably delighted because
there was a good chance that Hitler
might have been killed or at least that
there might be a plot that would and the
Nazi regime and if that happened that
regime might have gone to the Americans
and the British and said let's end the
war early let's spare humanity more
suffering and see if we can come to an
agreement we'll sue for peace and as I
got more and more into it I found that
actually in secret Roosevelt would have
had exactly the opposite response and
the reason for that was this Roosevelt
very early in World War two decided that
if we Americans fought the Germans and
we fought with the British we would not
do what we did in World War one which
was to fight the war and then finally
come in to come to a deal with the
Germans to stop the fighting and not
occupy in the country in the big way
Roosevelt felt that that was the mistake
that we made at the end of World War one
instead what he wanted to do in World
War two was fight the war - absolute
unconditional surrender no matter if
there was a group who said we've killed
Hitler who want to sue sue for peace no
matter
if there was some group in the German
government that said you know the
killing has gone on too long let's see
if we can stop this and arrive at some
kind of government in Berlin that you
Americans will be happy with and the
depth of Roosevelt's feeling about this
it went very deep things that I had not
even known about before Roosevelt for
instance said I was talking earlier
about the fact that many Americans
thought that Germans just loved war and
were destined to make war over and over
again Roosevelt agreed he thought it was
somehow in the German genes
he once said in private at one point I
think this war fever is so deep in the
Germans that we may have to castrate the
German men after the war so they won't
keep on reproducing people who cause
humanity all this suffering I don't
think he was speaking literally but it
shows you how deep that went at Tehran
when he met with Joseph Stalin and
Winston Churchill 1943 they were talking
about how do we keep Germany after World
War two from doing it to everyone again
and Stalin not exactly the most humane
guy on earth he had a suggestion he said
well my first suggestion is let's just
kill 50,000 German military officers if
you just remove all these people maybe
there will be no war fever ever again
for Stalin fifty thousand was a very
small number and given the number of
people he had purged within the Soviet
Union and then he said well 50,000 is
not enough let's kill a hundred thousand
in cold blood Franklin Roosevelt who
wanted to get along with Stone at that
point it also felt very similarly about
the Germans said well I think 50,000 is
too much let's make it 49 thousand five
hundred and at that point Churchill who
took all this literally was disgusted
and almost vomited he left the room and
said I won't be a party to a discussion
in such cold blood and finally Stalin
went out and grabbed Churchill brought
him back into the room and said I'm only
kidding Winston you could imagine if he
was kidding or not but the point is that
Roosevelt's very great feelings that in
World War two we had to have
unconditional surrender it did a couple
of things one was it no doubt lengths
the war we've all read so many military
histories about how long that war in
Europe really took I think it's
undeniable that the fact that Roosevelt
wanted to end it this way meant that the
Germans fought harder because they knew
that there was nothing for them to lose
in other words if they felt that they
could make a deal then perhaps there was
a reason to try to cooperate with the
Allies and it cost an awful lot of
soldiers Churchill privately was against
this idea because he knew that that
Britain had fewer soldiers than we
Americans did despair but the point is
from my point of view if it were not for
Roosevelt's I think courageous decision
to say we're not going to accept a deal
we're going to fight to unconditional
surrender we would never have a
situation that we now have in which we
were able to end that war and
essentially go into Germany from the
ground up and say there's no government
here we're going to occupy the country
50 years if necessary and build a
democracy that will be a beacon in
Europe and never threaten the world
again one thing you find when you find
when you look at Roosevelt in the way he
talked about the problem in private
Roosevelt thought he knew more about
Germany than probably any living person
in the American government and one thing
about Roosevelt is he thought he knew
more about most things than most people
in the American government had a huge
faith in his ability to absorb
information in this case he would say I
have a German history and that's why I
understand the Germans and I sort of
wondered what's the German history
turned out that Roosevelt was taken by
his parents to a spa in southern Germany
on a number of occasions during his
childhood and you know most of us would
think you know this doesn't exactly
qualify us but he was a german expert
and in private you know I understand the
Germans I was there and the problem with
the Germans is that they marched too
much or they like military music or they
like gliders it was always things like
this this is the way you fix the Germans
after World War to tell them they can't
March tell them they can't wear military
uniforms a little bit superficial as I
was listening to this and looking at all
this you know I began to think of myself
you know there's something to myself
there's something missing here and the
something missing here was very obvious
I mean it's obvious to us and 2002 if
we're gonna look back on the Germans and
what is wrong with the Germans in the
1940s it ain't marching at ain't
uniforms
it ain't gliders it's the fact that they
were committing the most monumental
crime in the history of the world they
were trying to murder an entire people
the Jewish people and others and this is
something that did not cross Roosevelt's
lips and it never appears in his
conversations with Winston Churchill he
never discussed it with Stalin and
Churchill at the summits and also for
about two years during the war he never
referred to this in private and I began
to studied a little bit harder and I
found that Roosevelt actually much
earlier than I realized
began learning about the Holocaust in
1942 he began to get witness reports of
things that people had seen reports of
what Hitler intended to do as the months
went on he got more and more information
people came and actually saw him and
described what they were seeing and
knowing Roosevelt you know I'm a
presidential historian and I've studied
Roosevelt for all these years my first
book was on Franklin Roosevelt knowing
what he was like what I would have
expected would have been that when
Roosevelt learned about this he would
have been horrified and he would have
spoken out he would have given an
immediate speech saying you know in case
you Americans have any doubt about what
we Americans are fighting against in
Europe you should know that these are
the kind of atrocities unprecedented in
human history in human history that the
Nazis are committing this is why we are
fighting we have to fight harder but in
1942 and 1943 and all through the early
months of 1944 Roosevelt was virtually
silent and that I could not understand
he didn't release the evidence he had
from my point of view that would have
been something that I think would have
steeled many Americans to feel we've
just got to fight harder because the
enemy is so dreadful and I found that
Jewish leaders and others went to
Roosevelt and said please it's very
important for you to give a speech say
the Nazis are murdering the Jewish
people and this is what we're fighting
against perhaps it will get to some of
the Nazis who are doing this
and they will realize that when the
Allies win the war this is something
that's so important to us Americans and
British that we're going to exact very
heavy penalties Roosevelt wouldn't do it
he said well I'm glad to in general
denounced the bad things the Nazis are
doing but he never went any further than
that and when you deal with something
like that you begin to wonder what was
on a president's mind in retrospect we
now know that the Holocaust was the
great crime in human history a big event
that FDR had to react to why was there
so little reaction and what I found was
that Roosevelt was very timid in certain
ways he was a strong courageous
president in seeing before many people
did that Hitler had to be stopped but on
this issue he was curiously silent and I
think it came from a couple of things
one was that when a Henry Morgenthau or
a leader of another ethnic group came to
him to ask for something for their
ethnic group especially during wartime
Roosevelt had a little bit of a sense
this is very antique thank God our
leaders these days would find this very
unusual but in those days he felt that
if a Jewish leader or an Irish American
came to him to ask for something that
had to do with war strategy it was
somehow unpatriotic I came across the
scene which early in the war FDR had
lunch with Henry Morgenthau his Treasury
secretary and a Catholic official named
Leo Crowley and he said you guys have
got to remember now this war is starting
that America is a Protestant country and
you Catholics and Jews are here under
sufferance and since you're here under
sufferance it's your responsibility to
go along with anything I ask you to do
and Morgenthau as I say was Roosevelt's
closest friend of the government but he
went back to his office and he just put
his fist to his head and he said what
the hell am i working so hard for if
this country is not for me and I am here
under sufferance that was Roosevelt's
attitude it led him to feel that if
someone came to him and said do more to
help refugees Jewish refugees and stop
the Holocaust it was somehow
illegitimate the other thing was that
especially in the run-up
World War two Roosevelt was always
sensitive to the charge that there were
too many Jews in the New Deal in the
Roosevelt administration and this was a
charge that was not only made during the
New Deal but on the eve of World War two
you had people like Charles Lindbergh
giving speeches saying that one of the
big groups that wants this war is the
Jewish people and they're doing it for
their own selfish reasons he was always
afraid of American anti-semitism in some
ways with very good reason
one thing he once said to a chrony in
private he said I think that if a
demagogue like Huey Long were ever to
take up American anti-semitism
anti-semitism in this country he said I
think there would be more blood flowing
through the streets of New York City
than there is today in Berlin that's how
strong Roosevelt thought that that
danger was and so the result of all this
is that in 1942 and 1943 although Jewish
leaders and others asked him to speak
out against the Holocaust to do more to
get Jewish refugees out of Europe and in
the United States so that their lives
would be saved he really dragged his
heels and I think as we think about
Roosevelt in history to my mind the most
important thing to know is that this is
the president who won World War two got
us into it and made sure that it saved
the world from Nazism and in so doing by
the way save two thirds of the world's
Jews but at the same time as a
presidential historian you always have
to go back to these decisions and I
would have to ask in retrospect
why didn't Roosevelt do more I had
mentioned Henry Morgenthau Morgenthau is
the figure that really moved me most in
this book as I was writing it as I've
mentioned he was Roosevelt's close
friend and neighbor in the Hudson Valley
in New York had been allied with him in
politics were probably 2025 years and as
I've suggested Roosevelt's closest
friend and government he was also only
the second Jew in history to be a member
of a president's cabinet as late as the
30s and 1940s and so as I was
researching this I wondered who was the
first turned out the first was a man
named Oscar Straus who was
Secretary of Commerce under Theodore
Roosevelt and there was a story about
him that goes like this
TR had a lot of Jewish support which he
wanted to reward so he wanted to give
the Commerce Department to an
influential Jewish supporter and asked
around and Oscar Strauss was the man who
has suggested so he got the job and
there was a rally in New York City
apparently not very long afterwards in
which TR asked an elderly Jewish leader
on the platform he said you know here's
old so-and-so and I just want you to
know that when I decided to look for a
Secretary of Commerce I didn't care
about the race I didn't care about the
Creed I just wanted to get the best man
get up here and tell tale tell this
audience how I made this decision and
the man unfortunately was hard of
hearing and hadn't heard what TR had
said and he got up and he said yes mr.
president I remember very well you told
me to find the best Jew I can possibly
find to go to the Commerce Department
the official record suggests that
embarrassment followed pulling out
making is that Morgenthau being Jewish
and being at the Treasury Department was
a very unusual thing in the 30s and 40s
and he was one of those who was very
worried about raising especially Jewish
matters with FDR Morgenthau once said
that the most important thing in his
life was his relationship with the
president his friend and FDR specialized
with everyone in making people insecure
Morgenthau was Roosevelt's close friend
but Roosevelt always made him feel he
once said that he would never have his
job tomorrow
and although he served in Roosevelt's
administration from the first day in 33
until the very end in 1945 Morgenthau
always felt so insecure that although he
was a quiet rich man he never bought a
house in Washington he moved from one
furnished residence to another because
he always thought that Franklin would
one day turn on him and he'd be out and
he'd have to get rid of this house very
quickly Morgenthau is remembered as I
say for being in the second Jew in the
cabinet but he was a very unobservant
Jew at the age of 50 he had never
attended to Passover Seder in his life
when his children were
asked what religion they were their
mother said just tell people that you're
an American this was not someone who was
very much involved in organized Judaism
and to such an extent that when he was
appointed Treasury Secretary Roosevelt's
patronage Chief Jim Farley said it's a
bad appointment because it'll make the
anti-semites angry and you won't get
credit from Jews because they think that
Morgenthau is too unobservant and part
of this was that Morgenthau while being
unobservant always did not want to have
roosevelt thinking that this is someone
who was always bringing jewish causes to
the president but there was a moment
that changed and it was a moment that
changed history and that was 1943 he was
in his office at the Treasury just a few
blocks from here
and he was called on by a man named
rabbi Stephen wise who had officiated at
Morgenthau wedding and wise said do you
have any idea what's going on in Europe
and Morgenthau said well explained to me
and wise began to describe what was
known about the deaf camps in the
murderer of by them millions of Jews and
he said do you know Henry that
lampshades are being made of the skins
of the Jews and at that point Morgenthau
felt faint and he said Stephen I can't
take it anymore and he left the room and
that was a moment that radicalized
Morgenthau he was never the same again
it transformed him from a very timid
reluctant person into a person of
courage because the way it affected him
was he said I don't give a damn I'm
gonna go into FDR and if he fires me
this is much too important there's foot
dragging on refugees Roosevelt is not
speaking out against the Holocaust now
is the time for him to act first thing
he did was Morgenthau went to the
Secretary of State Cordell Hull and you
always find in these stories these
wheels within wheels turns out that
Cordell Hull who was a tennessean had a
Jewish wife and this was something that
was almost not known by anyone because
whole four years had presidential
ambitions and in the 1930s in the 1940s
it was thought to have a Jewish wife
would kill your chances so this was
something that was very much hushed up
but Morgenthau knew it and he went to
Hull and said
people in your State Department are
keeping Jews from getting out of Europe
and coming into the United States to be
saved you've got to do something and
Hall said well there's not much I can do
and Morgenthau who was a plight man
decided to drop the politeness and he
said Cordell don't you realize that if
the Nazis came to America you'd be one
of the first to be put into a prison
camp and your wife would be sent to a
death camp even that had very little
influence on Howe so the result was that
Morgenthau in the supreme moment I think
of his life January 1944 went to
Roosevelt and he was carrying a document
which sits right in the National
Archives a few blocks from here and
what's the title the document the
document is called report to the
President on the acquiescence of this
government in the murder of the Jews
it's the kind of thing that Morgenthau
would never have dreamt of even
endorsing let alone taking into the Oval
Office
just a few months ago but he had been so
radicalized that he took this document
into the Oval Office and he said to FDR
this is what's going on and this has got
to stop you've got to do something about
this you can't be so quiet anymore and
if you don't you're in a very great risk
of having a political scandal especially
in election year in 1944 where people
are gonna say this is going on in Europe
and not only have you done very little
to stop it directly but people in your
state department or even aiding those
who are stopping the flow of refugees in
my line of work we always look for
figures in history who take a risk and
these days I think oftentimes we feel
that we find them too seldom because you
know in the year 2002 everyone has his
political or her political consultants
and polls everyone is told not to do the
stupid thing don't do something that's
gonna jeopardize your job but when you
find something like Henry Morgenthau
being willing to jeopardize what was it
the absolute center of his life which
was this cherished relationship almost
an older brother like relationship that
FDR had with him he threw the dice and
he confronted the president and it had
an effect because within weeks there was
a war refugee board to begin
trying to bring Jews out of Germany in a
big way and also Roosevelt finally gave
in March of 1944 the first date maybe he
ever gave saying that the Nazis are
involved in the worst crime in human
history the systematic murder of the
Jews another thing that came up at about
the same time was there were a number of
people who were looking for other ways
to stop the Holocaust and one suggestion
was that you bomb outfits you bomb some
of the other death camps perhaps also
the rail lines with the idea that you'd
probably end up killing the people who
were there but at least you'd stop the
means by which they are being killed and
given what we knew from history before I
did the work on this book the feeling
was that that suggestion was made a lot
to people in the White House and it
never got up to the president it went to
as high as an Assistant Secretary of War
named John John McCloy who turned it
down flat who said you know we are
trying to fight a war and I'm not going
to use the Pentagon in any way that is
not deliberately for the winning of the
war what I discovered and this is one of
the wonderful things about writing
history you sometimes find a document
that's just we call them Eureka
documents one document that stands
everything that we knew on its ear turns
out that about three years before mccloy
died he gave an interview to someone in
which he finally fessed up he said well
it turns out actually this decision went
beyond me I actually did go to see FDR
to ask him whether he wanted to bomb a
schvitz and the president turned out and
down the idea of flat said I think it'll
just kill a lot of people and it's not
going to do very much good I don't want
any part of it he said and this shows us
something that's good and something
that's bad and this is what history is
like the good thing is I think one of
the biggest decisions in history to face
a president was do you bomb the death
camps in 1944 and was there a chance to
stop the Holocaust
I always felt dreadful that this
important decision never got beyond and
a secretary
an Assistant Secretary of War so thank
God it did according to McCoy's
interview at the end of his life
the downside is that if this was as I
believe one of the great decisions to
face a president historically it's the
kind of thing you would have wanted a
president like FDR to give to experts
and argue will this help will this hurt
one of the ramifications and the thing
about FDR pardon was wonderful part of
him was dreadful the wonderful part was
he was so brilliant at using people and
keeping a hundred balls in the air at
any one time almost running World War
two cies single-handedly the downside
was that faced with a decision like this
he thought he could make a decision like
this too without the proper information
so rather than convening a committee and
examining all the possibilities this was
cavalier he came in do we bomb or not
Roosevelt said no quite casually turned
it down flat and that was the end of
that you could argue it round or flat in
retrospect I think there's a very great
possibility of that had the death camps
been bombed in 1944 many many lives
could be saved and many more perhaps it
might have been lost in the bombing so
from there what the story does is this
Morgenthau by then radicalized very
worried about what the Germans were
doing a ruled war - and worried even
more about what they might do after
World War two he went on a trip to
Europe to take a look at the
battlefields wanted to take a look at
France now that France was being
liberated after d-day in August of 1944
and while then he discovered that the
State Department other members of the
Roosevelt administration were making
plans what we do with Germany after VE
Day and the plans were this their idea
was Germany is going to be another
occupation problem just like what the
Americans did in Mexico or perhaps Spain
and the idea is to get Germany on its
feet it's quite as quickly as possible
so the Germans can feed themselves and
begin trading so that you know by 1947
or so Americans can pull out of Europe
and everything will be wonderful
Morgenthau who had been horrified by the
Holocaust and was very worried about
what the Germans might do even after
World
or to as many Americans were went to
Roosevelt and said you know you want
unconditional surrender you want to make
a democracy here from the ground up why
are you supporting these plans and
Morgenthau reacted and the way he
reacted was he had his people draw up an
enormous plan which once again you can
find both of the National Archives and
the Roosevelt Library which soon was
called the morgenthau plan' and what the
morgenthau plan' was essentially when we
defeat the Germans after VE Day
destroyed German industry flood the coal
mines reduced Germany to the level of a
basic agricultural estate that can't
make war let the Germans do in their own
juice suffer so that they will always
remember that they lost this war they'll
never want to make war again and the
interesting thing is that you would have
thought that Roosevelt on reading this
would have said it's too vindictive it
might create another war because might
make the Germans very resentful as they
were after World War one the interesting
thing is that when Morgenthau gave this
to Roosevelt fall of 1944 Roosevelt said
I think this is a good idea let's go
ahead with it
Roosevelt met with Winston Churchill at
Quebec shoda the morgenthau plan'
Churchill said I can't believe what I'm
looking at I mean not only is this
inhuman and undemocratic but you
decimate Germany this way then after VE
Day the Red Army the Soviet Union
they're going to roll right through
Europe you're gonna have a communist
Europe because there will be no Germany
to stop it nonetheless Roosevelt had
Churchill sign a document endorsing this
plan and what happened there was what
happened so often during the war rosid
all had more power than Churchill did
Churchill was desperately dependent on
the Americans and American aid and
Roosevelt essentially said unless you
sign on the dotted line I'm gonna
withdraw all aid to England after World
War two
and Churchill said you know I see good
things about the morgenthau plan' I
hadn't seen before
he said I'm converted and not only was
he converted but he actually drafted the
document himself saying how great the
morgenthau plan' was and so that's what
went on in Quebec
back here in Washington were Cordell
Hull Secretary of State at Henry Stimson
the Secretary of War who had been the
ones saying you know we've got to get
Germany on its feet as quickly as
possible they were told that Roosevelt
had put a gun at Churchill's had got him
to support this morgenthau plan' and
they were outraged and how did they
reply in 2002 you know when someone in a
president's cabinet does not like what
is done by the President or another
cabinet member occasionally it doesn't
happen very often but once in a blue
moon occasionally someone will leak the
idea to a newspaper so it will be
published and so when everyone will see
what a terrible idea this is and shoot
it down well the news is that's exactly
what was done in 1944 as well
Holland Stimpson leak this to the press
it appeared very quickly and the public
immediately knew what Roosevelt and
Churchill had done secretly at Quebec
and the result was that there was an
ugly argument between hull and Stimpson
on the one side and Morgenthau on the
other these were different times but as
you look at their Diaries it's not a
lovely picture Stimson would write in
his diary Jews shouldn't push the way
that Morgenthau is especially on an
issue like Germany he said it's Semitism
wild for vengeance he said and he went
to Morgenthau and he said the problem is
you just don't understand what we should
do with Germany he said the way to deal
with Germany is with Christianity and
kindness which is about the worst thing
he could have said to Morgan foe who was
deeply insulted and then once this all
became public the Germans got into the
act
Joseph Goebbels made a speech saying
that this morgenthau plan' is what the
Allies planned for Germany after the war
you Germans should fight hard to make
sure that 43 million of you are not
murdered and he said this is a Jewish
murder plan that shows the kind of thing
that FDR wants to do deeply ugly and it
happened largely in public during the
war even during a campaign in the fall
of 1944 and the interesting thing is
that as I studied Roosevelt hour-by-hour
by the fall of nineteen
forty-four Roosevelt was a much sicker
man than I had realized his medical
records once again in the National
Archives in the FDR library were
released not long ago and as doctors by
1944 found that Roosevelt was in what
they called cardiac failure they felt
that he only was bound to live a matter
of time and the people around Roosevelt
they didn't let it be known by the
American public at the time especially
because people were voting on him but
you'd see these scenes that I got in my
book where Roosevelt the blood was
beginning to get less and less coming to
his brain and you'd see these scenes
were Roosevelt would sign an important
document what do we do about Germany or
what do we do about the soldiers
fighting in Europe and then a day later
someone would come to him and say how
could you have signed that it's the
opposite of what you're thinking and
Roosevelt would look at the document
with his signature and say I never
signed this thing in my life I've never
seen this more and more often this
happened it was not very public he might
have lost the election 44 if people knew
what you see at the end of 44 more and
more is not only Roosevelt who is less
and less able to cope in this way but
also a Roosevelt who begins and again
you see this in Diaries that have just
been opened quite recently a Roosevelt
who in private knew what was happening
to him and was beginning to think that
perhaps he should not remain as
president he says to a number of his
intimates a number of times late 44 and
early 1945
I'll get reelected I'll become president
for a fourth term but I don't want to
stay because I just don't have it
anymore he said perhaps I'll quit the
presidency in 44 or 45 after World War
two ends and interesting the one thing
he talked about doing after the war and
after leaving the presidency leaving it
to Harry Truman was becoming Secretary
General the first Secretary General of
the United Nations and so much did he
think about this he actually talked
about putting the UN at Hyde Park near
his house and so it'd be convenient to
him and that be a little airstrip
foreign leaders could come and fly in
and see him and that's the way he saw
his retirement of course that didn't
happen because his illness was much more
advanced and he realized and he died
abruptly
in April 1945 and did so I've got a
scene in the book the day after his
final dinner which he spent with Henry
Morgenthau they ate dinner and argued
the whole time about what you'd do about
Germany after World War two
April 12 1945 we were about three weeks
away from VE Day and even then Roosevelt
had not yet decided so Roosevelt is dead
and into the vacuum comes Harry Truman a
president who had had very little
training and foreign policy Roosevelt
had barely spoken to him they had been
together in Washington maybe about three
days of Truman's vice presidency
Truman hadn't been told about the a-bomb
he knew virtually nothing about what
Roosevelt's plans were for Germany or
Europe or very much else and so you have
these scenes of Truman in the basement
of the White House reading his eyes out
millions of pages of documents to try to
find the secret of what Roosevelt wanted
and the fact is of course it was in no
document it was really in Roosevelt's
head and so Truman had to very quickly
improvise what Truman knew he wanted was
not Morgenthau or Morgenthau his plan
and so often in history you find that
great historical events turn on petty
animosities I know that doesn't happen
in Washington these days but during
World War two once in awhile it did and
the key to Truman's attitude toward
Morgenthau was as follows Truman was
elected senator from Missouri 1934 as
many of you know as an icon of the Tom
Pendergast machine of Kansas City many
people thought that he was sort of a
corrupt figure that had been sent here
by this party boss Democratic boss in
Kansas City Truman was super-sensitive
every time someone was not as friendly
to him as he thought that he should be
treated he thought they're treating me
badly because they think that I'm sort
of below the salt
I'm the slightly sleazy figure that they
don't want to have any anything to do
with and what happened was Truman went
to call on the Treasury secretary in
1935 Henry Morgenthau
and he was told that Morgenthau was not
in
and from that day onward he assumed that
Morgenthau was in but assumed that
Truman was such a dirty figure but
Morgenthau did not want to shake hands
with him Morgenthau had no idea of this
but when Truman became president it was
not great news for Morgenthau because
you had a new president who had been
disposed against him from that day in
1935 and so very quickly what happened
was Truman decided to turn against
Morgenthau and his plan he fired
Morgenthau and essentially decided with
Stimson went to Potsdam and carried out
a plan to make Germany a democracy at
the same time you know you're always
trying to get into these people's heads
Truman made a lot of decisions that were
the decisions of what I think is a very
great president especially that given
the fact that this was someone who was
so badly prepared at the same time you
find these things about people that show
how complex they were for instance
Truman in April 1945 just a few days
after he was president you look at the
newspapers and on the front page of the
newspapers are Buchenwald and Belson the
death camps are opening for the first
time Americans actually saw pictures of
the inmates being released and if you go
into the records of that time even many
American anti-semites when they saw
these pictures they would say how could
I have said such things or thought such
things look at how this people has
suffered I mean it changed a lot of
American opinion but you look at Harry
Truman's Diaries and this is something I
just cannot explain even though he was
seeing the same pictures you'll see
things in his diaries where he's saying
things like the Jews think they're God's
chosen people I think God had better
judgment and other ethnic epithets he
assures Henry Stimson that neither
Morgenthau nor any of those Jew boys
will go to Potsdam to meet with with
Churchill and Stalin and it's horrible
but it's also what makes these guys so
interesting because this is the same
president that later on went on to
recognize the State of Israel in 1948
and you wonder how someone could have
during the day made decisions that were
so humane and sometimes at night written
things into his
diary that were almost like dr. Jekyll
and mr. Hyde
so the dennou mall was this you went
through this war we won the war in 1945
by then Germany was not the danger that
it had been before because as Roosevelt
had no reason to expect during the war
in 1945 Harry Truman had something that
was a permanent check against a German
Germany that tried to make trouble and
that was the atomic bomb by 1945 in
Potsdam the great worry was no longer
Germany with the Soviet Union and so
what we Americans did in post-war
Germany was to use that blank slate that
Franklin Roosevelt and offered us
unconditional surrender to occupy
Germany and try to create a democracy
and one quote I've got in the book that
says that I think just perfectly Dwight
Eisenhower who was the first military
governor of Germany after we Allies
invaded and occupied liberated he was
talking to his staff October of 1945 in
Frankfurt and he said you know you think
you guys think that World War two has
been successful we don't know that yet
he said the test of whether you're world
war two in Europe was successful it's
not today it's not ten years from now
it's going to be fifty years from now he
said if in 1995 Germany is a peaceful
democracy then we will have succeeded
and you advance the clock fifty years he
got it almost right on the nose Germany
was unified in 1990 it's a country with
an awful lot of shortcomings but we have
our soldiers we have Franklin Roosevelt
we have Harry Truman to thank for coming
up with that strategy through all sorts
of twists and turns and shortcomings
that I write about in the book but we
have them more than any other American
to thank for the fact that we in this
day and age not only have a Germany
that's a democracy but a Europe that's
turning into that direction as well and
I close the book with a scene I make the
point that leaders who are fighting wars
oftentimes when they get discouraged
they think about what would happen if
you lose the war and this was true of
FDR and
and even though these were pretty
self-confident people Roosevelt for
instance when he met with Churchill at
Quebec in 1944 they had a chat about
what Hitler might have done had he
invaded London and succeeded in 1940 and
Harry Truman went in 1945 he went
through the ruins of defeated Berlin he
began to think what would Hitler have
done to Washington and to the United
States if Hitler had won World War two
and it's a game it's a fascinating game
for a Nestorian to play and I write
right about at the end of the book you
know what would America be like if
Hitler had won I mean it would be a land
of utterly unspeakable cruelty needless
to say you can imagine what Washington
would look like the capital of the White
House the Washington Monument probably
would have swastikas it certainly would
be bereft to synagogues or Jews probably
the Nazis would have had Roosevelt's
house at Hyde Park and Truman's house at
Independence Missouri demolished to make
sure that these would not be rallying
points for people who would oppose Nazi
domination of America it's a fascinating
game to play a horrible game what would
this country have been like if things
had gone the other way and another way
to think about it as I write in the book
is what were Hitler's plans if he had
won the war what would Germany have
looked like and we actually know because
some of his people wrote about this and
in some of the documents that once again
are here in the National Archives some
of the captured German documents and we
know that had Hitler won the war he
planned to remake Berlin basically level
it and remake it into a city called
Germania with enormous halls that were
probably a hundred times the size of the
American capital buildings that look
sort of like the cessful be to be a
pageant of an oriental despot for
instance there was a long hallway so
that if you were a chief of state come
to call on Hitler
you'd have to hike for about a half a
mile so that you'd be out of breath by
the time you were admitted to the
Furious presence it would have been
horrible and absolute but now because
what Germania Berlin would have looked
like would have been sort of a bad
version of
a architectural student working out of a
textbook but the wonderful thing is you
begin to think how Germany and how
Berlin today looks so much different
from what Hitler intended and it really
makes the point of how much we were able
to do when we won this war and any of
you who have been to Berlin recently you
look at that architecture it's of all
kinds there are kids walking around with
purple spiked hair and rings through
their cheeks is exactly what Hitler
would have absolutely detested and
Hitler wanted World War two memorials in
Berlin and there are but the wonderful
thing is thanks to the fact that we won
the war the more memorials are not to
Himmler and they're not to Goebbels and
they're not to Hitler but the memorials
that are there are to the people who
actually tried to kill Hitler and tried
to build a democracy and to bring this
all full circle back to what I was
talking about the beginning if you want
to find for instance Hitler's bunker
where he died you can find where it is
but first you're gonna have to go
through this wonderful corporate
architecture Sony and all the buildings
that never would have been there had
Hitler won and you'll also have to go
past a very big columns memorial to the
victims of the Holocaust that's just
rising this year and the other thing is
that if you want to go to Hitler's
military headquarters there it is the
headquarters where Stauffenberg was
murdered on that night of the day he
tried to kill Hitler in July of 1944 but
the wonderful thing is that it's no
longer military headquarters it's now
been turned into an museum to honor the
conspirators who tried to kill Hitler
and it was on mendler Street the street
is not any longer called bend ler the
street nowadays is called Stauffenberg
Street thank you very much
Michael Beschloss is author of the
conquerors Roosevelt Truman and the
destruction of Hitler's Germany 1941 to
1945 it's published by Simon & Schuster